what's happening people welcome back to
the show it is a
72nd episode it would have been 700 but
huberman took that spot so I guess I can
really kick him off to do this arbitrary
runr of lessons if you are relatively
new here over the last 100 episodes you
might not know that around about every
hundred I recap a bunch of lessons that
I've got from the show or from life or
from writing my newsletter and I get to
run through them so today you're going
to get to go through as many as I've got
time for from the last 9 months or so
and there are some absolute bangers in
there before I get started if you
haven't already neonic is live now my
first ever product it is the only thing
that you need to drink to get absolutely
dialed in no matter what you need to do
to be more focused attentive to improve
your memory this thing is phenomenal
so without further Ado by the way new
tonic.com if you need that without
further Ado your expectations Define
your happiness more than your
circumstances and this is something that
I knew intuitively but needed a couple
of quotes to kind of really synthesize
it so Tim Urban says if you only wished
to be happy this could be easily
accomplished but we wish to be happier
than other people and this is always
difficult for We Believe others are
happier than they are monu said this 300
years ago and we're still working on
this one so Tim Urban resurfacing that
famous
quote really highlights the asymmetry
between what we see of ourselves and
what we see of everyone else right
because humans are comp comparative
relative beings we don't just judge what
we are in isolation we judge it as a
part of the entire hierarchy of society
it's not just about being in a situation
and it being good it's about being in a
better situation than we were before and
also a better one than the people that
were around and also a better one than
our parents were in when they were our
age this is a intergenerational
competition Theory it's referred to as
Charlie Munga had a really great Insight
where he said um The World Isn't driven
by greed it's driven by Envy our lives
are objectively the best Humanity has
ever had yet complaining and dis
dissatisfaction is as high as ever and
also because everyone usually only shows
the world the best of themselves this
means that we see our own misery and our
failings and foibles and vacillation
from a front row seat while we watch the
Highlight Reel of everyone else and this
makes us think that other people are
doing better than they really are and
when we feel the Delta between Where We
Are and where we imagine they are it
hurts right there is no such thing as
objective wealth everything is relative
and most relative to those around you
that's from Morgan housel and there's
kind of a way to look at this that your
circumstances are one uh indication of
your happiness but your expectations are
one too and you can either bring your
circumstances up to meet your
expectations or try as best you can to
bring your expectations down but the
problem is no one is going to
feel fired up or romantic about the
opportunity of leaving Lots on the table
right this isn't very hosy pilled to say
oh yeah I'm just going to expect less of
myself I'm going to leave as much as I
can on the table because I understand
that the gap between my circumstances
and my expectations are where happiness
sits so by having lower expectations I
can increase my happiness that doesn't
it kind of feels like like folding
almost to this uh ineffable Force that's
out there trying to crush us but I don't
know I think I think there's something
to it in as much as you
can take satisfaction in the things that
you have done uh I was talking to Dan
Bilzerian someone that you might not
think of as a a font of like life bro
wisdom but he's a really smart guy and
we were talking about how um each time
that you achieve a new level of
success it essentially just creates a
new bar for you to meet again in the
future and that sounds I don't know it
might sound kind of trite but the
problem with a rapid increase in status
or wealth or or Accolade or whatever is
that all that you're thinking about is
oh God that's now the new bar that I
need to get to so for instance let's say
that we release a a YouTube video and it
breaks some record for a 24-hour plays
let's say it does a million plays in an
hour which I think in a day which is
around about our current record there is
Elation at the fact that we've done it
but then there's also this uh
despondency in the back of your mind
where you think oh my God that's the new
bar in order for us to get another best
record we have to do a million 1.1
million plays in a day and that's
terrifying it's also a reason I think
why I'm not so bought in on universal
basic income being a solution if AI
automates all of our jobs and starts
producing better podcasts than me
because as soon as humans reach an
acceptable level of existence they start
wanting to push for more in order to
stand out from the crowd and a flat
hierarchy doesn't stick about for long
so even if every single person earns the
same amount of money people will just
find something else to compete on right
so in in
20100 when everyone's needs are met and
nobody needs to go to work or something
we're all going to be uh collecting
leaves or wives or social credit score
system points or something like it you
are naturally going to stratify out into
a hierarchy because it is not about your
absolute happiness it is all about your
relative happiness your relative
attractiveness your relative wealth Gad
sad said this on the episode a couple of
weeks ago right he said um if you want
to be happy and satisfied with your sex
life you not only need to have the
amount of sex that you want but you want
to be having a little bit more sex than
all of your friends around you so yeah
um happiness and uh satisfaction in life
does not exist in a vacuum as as much as
you and me may think oh yeah fantastic I
can do this from first
principles that's not the way that it
works so yeah uh be careful about your
expectations another one about Mono
thinking which got some uh backs up on
the Internet a couple of weeks ago which
was great uh was by Ginder Bogle he says
you can gauge someone's Ignorance by the
number of phenomena they explain with
the same answer those who blame many
different issues like War poverty and
pollution on just one cause like
capitalism are recycling explanations
because the demand for answers outstrips
their
supply so good man the demand for
answers outstrips their supply so they
keep on repurposing the only answer that
they do know everything is because of
toxic masculinity or everything is
because of climate change or everything
is because of progressive ideology or
whatever it is right and it got me onto
another idea which might explain why you
get ostracized sometimes for not being a
card carrying extremist or a cookie
cutter idealog so if I know one of your
views and from it I can accurately
predict everything else that you believe
then you're not a serious thinker right
so if you tell me your view on abortion
and from it I know your stance on
immigration and Healthcare and gun
control and vaccines and Taxation it
seems likely that you haven't arrived at
all of those beliefs on your own rather
you just unquestioningly adopted an
entire Suite of beliefs from some group
right you've outsourced your worldview
to the crowd and these people are very
predictable right I can be very
confident about what they'll say if a
new social campaign movement comes along
because it's exactly the same as what
everybody else in their group will say
and this is why anyone who thinks for
themselves and doesn't adhere to a
cookie cutter ideology whale is so
unpopular right you are an unreliable
Ally surely you you might agree with me
on abortion but I know that you
disagreed with me on your opinion of
Donald Trump so I'm uh very skeptical of
you in the future right these unreliable
allies need to be treated with much more
skepticism and distance and in a tribal
Warfare game the most reliable members
are the most popular and I think that
this is something
reassuring to remember if you ever feel
like you don't fit in or
like people sometimes don't treat you
with the same degree of uh like tribal
acceptance that you notice other people
do even people who are perhaps
compromising what they believe
compromising their
um you're aware that they don't actually
believe the things that they're saying
yet they say them and somehow members of
the group would rather have a lying
compatriot than an honest adversary or
even just like an honest associate right
and um yeah I think I felt that a good
bit
myself I felt that um whether it's being
accused of on the same video being a
blue pilled cck and a uh a right-wing
bigot right by by opposite people point
in the same in this opposite direction
it's just um it's an interesting one and
it's reassuring uh in some ways and this
leads into probably my favorite new idea
that I'm kind of obsessed by at the
moment which is the abalene Paradox the
abalene Paradox is a situation in which
a group makes a decision that is
contrary to the desires of that group's
members because each member assumes the
others approve of it it explains how a
number of accurate individuals can
become idiots when they get together so
think Emperor's New Clothes right an
acquaintance invites you to his wedding
despite not wanting you there because he
thinks you want to attend you attend
despite not wanting to because you think
he wants you there or at a a business
meeting someone suggests an idea that he
thinks the others will like uh for
instance recruiting a trans influencer
is the face of a brand each member has
misgivings about what it is but assumes
that the others will consider them
transphobic if they speak out so
everyone approves the idea despite no
one actually liking it or uh every
member of a family in North Korea hates
communism but they never mention this to
each other because each assumes that the
others approve of it and I think I
wondered for a good while about
how rational people that I knew in
private held uh quite balanced beliefs
or quite normal beliefs or just a uh a
relatively normal worldview seem to
change an awful lot when they got into a
group and not just in a a performative
way but that their actual you know like
ground ethics seemed to adjust like
there were a different person not only
in presentation but in content too in
substance as well
so it's
just again it's reassuring I think if
you're somebody that sits anywhere
outside of the absolute cookie cutter
extremist on both sides ideology you are
going to be observed as an unreliable
Ally by the people that are further out
to the right or the left than you
because they are by definition more
predictable the the further toward the
middle that you get the less predictable
you are and
this whether it's to do with sports
right if you're the sort of person that
will both praise and criticize your
sports team right or or or praise and
criticize your child sports team all of
these things the lack of predictability
the lack of a cook cutter ideology about
anything means that people will treat
you with more skepticism because in the
future they can't accurately project
whether or not you're going to be on
their side or on the side of someone
else that they absolutely hate or
somewhere else that they haven't even
thought of much much easier ah yeah we
don't need to worry about JN John's
John's always John's Sweet John's Sweet
John's John's always on our side so yeah
I think useful lesson to know uh another
one that I actually had Illustrated
recently which was pretty cool by um V
Andre was about the reason that you
should stop taking advice from super
successful people and i' noticed that
there's a trend of people who've made it
explaining how work life balance is
actually what's most important and how
you can't be powered by resentment or a
sense of insufficiency or a chip on your
shoulder or whatever and it's a failure
I think on the part of the guru to
understand that the tools you need to
get from nor to 50 and not the same that
you need to get from 90 to 95 and it's
also a basic failure of memory right
when you look at what got that person to
where they are it's precisely the traits
that they're now castigating almost
almost everybody has more pain and
resentment and fear in the beginning
which is why they all use it and once
you've achieved enough success and
validation from the world to not be
fueled by that anymore that's great but
that doesn't mean that people who are
just starting out can achieve the
success that you now have by using
strategies which you only accessed after
becoming successful right like it's
almost like uh the luxury belief of
success kind of like Rob Henderson's
luxury beliefs idea um defund the police
for instance was pushed heavily by
people that live in communities that
didn't need a massive police presence
and you need holistic balance Drive is
pushed by people who already benefited
from their resentment fueled Obsession
for a decade
right like we have to be very careful
modeling off what successful
statusfull behave to achieve success
instead it would be what did my favorite
Guru actually do when they were at my
stage because that is a much more
realistic idea of how you can emulate
what they're doing Ali abdal has this
great idea where he says about how um
you want to be teaching people that are
three steps behind you because when
you're 10 steps ahead you can't remember
the problems that you were having 10
steps ago and everybody falls into this
trap right you the theory of mind again
stepen pink is idea about uh the curse
of knowledge like once you know a thing
you can't imagine what it's not like to
not know that thing
and the the ability for people to jump
back by you know three years five years
a decade 20
years is basically impossible they can't
remember where they were at and we don't
have some you know photographic memory
of the texture of our mind and of the
way that we spent our time so yeah a
much better way to do it if you're
looking at someone is not to listen to
what they're saying but to look at what
they did when they were at the same
stage as you um talking about realistic
paths to difficult things I came up with
this idea about a realistic path to
Enlightenment so as much as moving to a
cave right in the woods and spending a
decade in silent Retreat might be great
for your spirit it's not going to be
doable by pretty much anyone and if
you've meditated enough you know that
you accumulate momentum in mindfulness
kind of like a
swell moving underwater and after enough
time there's kind of a force and a power
to your ability to drop into the present
moment and sometimes even little waves
of genuine calm Insight break above the
surface it's lovely but if you're
anything like me it doesn't result in an
extended self-perpetuating Enlightenment
it doesn't even really work on its own
where your mindfulness sneaks up on you
and you're in the present moment without
realizing and I've done you know 1500
sessions of meditation over the last 5
years more so consistent meditation and
a focus on mindfulness strengthens the
thinking muscle that you use to Wrangle
your mind to actually exist right now
you you learn to punctuate your day with
instances where your mind finally
settles into the moment and then it's
gone but then you can get back later in
the day and as as far as I can tell this
is the realistic path to
Enlightenment you're never going to
become fully Bliss Out In Perpetual
non-dual astral realm synchronicity
right but you can string together a few
moments of Peace So that at least for a
few times each day your mind rests where
your feet are and I always used to think
that this was a failure if I can achieve
mindfulness but then I lose it that's
still not persistent Enlightenment so I
failed and instead I think it's smart to
reframe the goal if you can just have
your mind and your feet in the same
location five or 10 times a day then
that's a good start and then maybe you
can do 15 or 20 or 100 and that seems
importantly both attainable and really
useful and um just finding these moments
where you can catch yourself this you
know Sam haris said it on the episode
that I did with him this is who inspired
this and he
said he was late coming to the
podcast and he was rushing around in the
house rushing rushing rushing and him
and his wife was leaving at the same
time and they were passing each other as
he was sorting his shoes or whatever and
then he just caught himself stopped
picked her up gave her a kiss put her
down and left and you know that's a 10c
punctuation of whatever obsessive
machinations you've got going on in your
mind that you're currently captured by
until you stop and you look and you
realize where you are and your mind and
your feet are in the same location and
you do something with so much more
intentionality and
presence and then you move on with your
day and stringing together sequences of
those kinds of moments to
me seems
like it's so so much more attainable
it's so much more
realistic uh that that's kind of what
I'm aiming for at the moment and maybe
you know the Jed McKenna out there my
fledgling Jed McKenna who's like this
super enlightened spiritual
teacher uh would maybe that's me being
cooked and leaving it on the table
but again you know that expectations and
happiness thing if your expectation is
the only time that I can be satisfied or
feel um grateful for the work that I've
put in on a mindfulness uh level is when
I finally reach complete non-dual
[__]
Enlightenment it's not going to happen
uh for pretty much anybody so you're
perpetually going to be dissatisfied
with your own mindfulness practice
whereas I think this this seems to work
and I know that I can do it I've done
every single person listening to this
this ever treding mindfulness which is
almost all of you knows that you can do
you're washing the dishes and you just
catch yourself and you actually feel the
water hitting your hands right or I love
to do this when I'm driving which is one
of the saddest things about not driving
out here in Austin yet because it takes
forever to get a driver's license in
America the leather on the steering
wheel of my car had little perforations
in it and I remember if I was sat at
traffic lights like really trying to
feel every single perforation on the
steering wheel and it just puts you into
the genuinely puts you into the present
moment and you know that you can do it
and you know that if you strung 50 of
those together every single day that's
pretty [__] enlightened to me so
anyway that's my realistic path to
Enlightenment uh you might have seen
that I was hanging about with Jimmy Carr
uh obviously he came on the show but
we've been talking for quite a while
turns out that he's a a big fan of
modern wisdom and we've been chatting a
lot on WhatsApp and exchanging ideas and
then he
did my show my show and our episode and
Rogan's dropped I think within two days
of each other even though mine had been
recorded like three or four weeks before
and uh he brought up to Joe this idea
that me and him had both been working on
for a little while which is the 24-hour
you and this is one of the best
questions I think to ask yourself when
faced with a decision which is what
would you tomorrow want you today to do
and it's something that I've relied on
for a long time to help me get
perspective and make better choices the
reason that it's so effective I think is
it rips you out of the moment and it
stops you from relying so heavily on the
confused chemical signals coming from
your body and instead it it gives you a
bit more distance it depersonalizes the
decision it helps you treat yourself
like a friend that you're responsible
for helping in Peterson language uh it
forces you to optimize for long-term
thinking rather than immediate
gratification uh it reminds you that
ultimately decisions aren't being made
for you now they're being made for you
in 24 hours and 24 days and 24 months
you can see
our decisions as Investments that we
make into our future and the more
ruminative and deep of a thinker that
you are the more you need to make
decisions for your future self and not
yourself now does that make sense so
optimizing to gratify your desires in
the moment at the expense of the way
that you will feel and the story that
you will tell yourself about yourself in
the
future is rarely a good deal because you
live with the story of your decisions
for far longer than the impact of them
so you have to Choose
Wisely and we don't have crystal balls
right to see the future but this is
about as close
to Clairvoyance as I can think like in
fact I can't think of a single decision
which would be worse if I actually did
what I wished that I'd done 24 hours
later and
I can't imagine if all you did was
things that you wanted to do now but you
in the future would regret like that's a
just direct path toward misery right
like I I it's a guaranteed way to make
decisions which you're going to have to
not only live with the consequences of
but for even longer than that you're
going to have to live with the story
that you tell yourself about being the
kind of person who made that sort of
decision and again especially if you're
you know introspective reflective
ruminative sort of person who's going to
think about the things that you do and
tell yourself a story about what that
means about you you need to be very very
careful about what you invest into that
future story of you uh because you
know the negativity bias is a hell of a
drug and if it wants if you have a
predisposition to think of yourself as a
bit of a piece of [__] you will
permanently be Scouting For
any excuse to fit your prior oh yeah I
knew I I knew that I was always going to
do that thing I I I I've not changed at
all this proves to me that I'm not the
person that I thought it was so yeah
decisions are as much about the sort of
person that you will tell yourself that
you are for having made the decision as
the actual impact of the decision itself
and uh what would you tomorrow want you
today to do pretty bulletproof uh but
difficult right very difficult to do
because it gives you pretty much nowhere
to hide there's essentially nowhere to
hide at all and uh when you do make bad
decisions it's on
you anyway uh there was another one from
Jed McKenna who again spiritual
enlightenment now uh it just this guy's
writing is so interesting he writes with
this degree of clarity he's either an
unbelievable writer and charlatan all
definitely completely enlightened and
and and crazy dude um I love his books
anyway Jim OES he got me onto them and
he's got this quote that I've been
thinking about for a while which is it
relates to how hard we try to control
our lives he says fear and ego are
keeping your hand on the tiller release
the tiller for whatever reason and the
steering takes care of itself
so if you think about what life would be
like if you didn't grip the tiller so
hard the tiller is the handle attached
to the rudder on a boat it's the thing
that steers it and just thinking about
you know you life is chaotic and there
is a swell or a storm coming and you you
grip on hard you try to Wrangle control
of your life more by applying more
effort and pressure and cognitive
horsepower and it relates to something
probably my favorite ever video from or
Marcus so he's stood on stage at the
announcement of his New York Times best
bestselling book party and he
says I spent so much of my life
terrified of what I was going to become
and whether I was going to be right here
right now God how much time did I waste
afraid I wasn't going to be right here
right now if I could change the only
thing I'd change about my whole life
would be fearing less that I wouldn't
get right here the place I was going
anyway I wouldn't change all the
mistakes and mishaps I needed those but
all the constant worry that I wasn't
going to make it that took me out of the
moment it took me out of enjoying these
experiences or smiling or eating my
lunch or whatever I was doing know your
mission have faith you're going to get
there wherever you go it's going to be
all right just find ways to get out of
your
head pretty good so if you imagine that
the outcomes in your life are
predetermined right imagine that where
you're going to end up the achievement
of your goals the attainment of your
Pursuits are predestined and you're
going there no matter how much you fear
or worry now you still need to do the
work you still need to do the things but
you don't need to fear about completing
the work or worry about whether you'll
do the things the things you need to do
will get done and the ones that you
don't won't how differently would you
experience life you'd be able to just be
right in the world but not of the world
doing the things but not afraid of the
things according to Jed he says You
observe events and you allow the flow of
things to do the steering and you go
where you go and I really think that
there is something to this release the
tiller is a mantra that I should tattoo
on the inside of my eyelids and it's
good to be reminded of when we find
ourselves gripping too hard to fears or
expectations because why fear about
whether you're going to go to the place
that you were going all along
and it's a delicate balance
between agency you know which is one of
the words that I use the most on this
podcast trying to internalize that locus
of control you are able to make changes
to your life you are able to lean in etc
etc but there is also a degree
of an anxiety and and concern and
rumination and Obsession and neuroticism
which is no longer helpful it's it's not
a part of you taking control it's
outside of you taking control and you
faking or you confusing what you think
for how you impact the
world that to me is uh a really nice
reframe release the tiller so another
one of the topics that we've spoken
about a lot over the last couple of
months is been masculinity
and you know a lot of guests a lot of
female guests as well which I do
appreciate I
wish I wish that by the way how
beautiful is this can look at that get
in there look at that puppy
um I
wish in some regards that it was more
accepted for men to be talking about
masculinity again not to say that it's
not but you know Politico did a
seven-part series on men and there were
zero male writers for it uh probably the
most famous masculinity focused article
over the last six months was Christine
Ember
female uh you know so many of the people
that I've been speaking to about this
are women
and I get the impression at the moment
that guys would happily take anyone
speaking about their problems so you
know like a beggar on the street you
know like give me the end of your
sausage roll or give me two pens or give
me whatever like I'll take what you get
but um I do wish
that it was easier for men to have this
conversation without having to prostrate
themselves right on the well I I I must
before we get started I must say that by
focusing on the problems of men we're
not ignoring the problems of women and
I'm aware that for a long time you know
men did have some privileges apart from
the war and the disease and the only 40%
of us
reproducing all of that like these
unnecessary caveats and the hurdles that
guys need to jump over especially in
some regards if you're a young dude that
goes to the gym right you're just
branded as some right-wing Firebrand
Andrew Tate like [__] from wish
because that is how the mainstream media
has captured all of the conversations
around men and it's just it it that bit
that bit sucks but
anyway I was trying after the
conversations that I'd had to work out
why men struggling and and is largely a
thankless task like why is it that it's
so hard to give men any attention or to
give them much attention in the
mainstream media and I think it's
because of a zero sum view of empathy so
there's an assumption that any attention
paid toward men takes it away from women
or some other minority group who is more
deserving like after all haven't men had
it good for long enough maybe they
should just suck it up for a while but
empathy doesn't work in this way right
like it's not a limited resource and
recognizing the plights of men does not
ignore the plights of women and
ultimately women end up suffering in any
case because it's this increasing cohort
of apathetic checked out resentful men
who contribute to the exact lack of
eligible partners that women say that
they're struggling with so the women who
post like mocking tweets saying boohoo
poor patriarchy sad whilst also
complaining where are all of the Good
Men at it's just mating logic seppuku
right like they're just it it if one sex
loses both sexes lose and I think the
difference is the main difference is
that at least when it comes to women's
problems and they have any of them I
think that you know five or 10 years
time the actual big story is going to be
uh male body image and female crisis of
femininity uh I think that it's going to
Pivot whereas at the moment it's mostly
in terms of the way that people appear
women's body standards and body types uh
and men's mental health I think that's
going to flip based on the trends male
uh body dysmorph is is set to overtake
women's within the space of the next two
decades so everything's going to go up
side down but
anyway male blame right a common
question I think is why don't men just
do better right surely they can just try
harder in school and employment and in
health it's like Chop Chop men hurry up
and stop being so useless but no other
group is told that when they suffer with
poor performance or accolades in the
real world that they should just pull
themselves up by their bootstraps like
we don't tell any other group
that they should just talk about their
problems instead we spend billions in
taxpayer funded money and private
charity to set up committees and
departments and campaigns and funds to
solve the problem so if a woman has a
problem we ask what can we do to fix
society and if a man has a problem we
ask what can men do to fix themselves
and it's a blatant double standard and
anyone who is unwilling to admit the
structural disadvantages faced by men
are standing in the way of us solving
the problems that are hurting men and
the potential wives that they should be
viable for right the problems are not in
men's heads but they're out there in
society and we shouldn't Gaslight men
into thinking that they can solve these
problems by just being less toxically
masculine like if the patriarchy is so
powerful why aren't men flourishing more
right the the single biggest risk to a
man under the age of 40 is his own hands
Christine Ember had this really lovely
quote where she said um many men feel
that their difficulties are often
dismissed out of hand as whining from a
patriarchy that they don't feel a part
of just because you're in the majority
doesn't mean you don't need support So
in this regard Modern Men are being made
to pay for the sins and the advantages
that perhaps their fathers and their
grandfathers enjoyed and you know it's
it's
just it's such a shame
that Mena men are kind of told if only
you were less masculine if only you were
more like a woman like most of the the
only in fact mainstream publicly
acceptable versions of masculinity look
an awful lot like traditional femininity
men need to open up more about their
emotions they need to not be so focused
on status and Prestige and Mastery and
conquering
uh their aggression needs to be tuned
down all you know well okay like I I get
that but that's not fixing masculinity
that's nuturing masculinity right it's
it's not uh sanitizing the bad elements
that men are struggling from it's
sterilizing them altogether and yeah
it's just it's not going to work it's
ultimately not going to work because
you're fighting against
biology and then there was a study I
wish I'd read it earlier on but Dr John
Barry he was on the show maybe six
months ago Center for male psychology
the lead for the center of male
psychology he said um having a negative
view of masculinity damages boys and
men's mental health brand new research
assessing the views of over 4,000 men
found that thinking masculinity is bad
for your behavior is linked to having
worse mental well-being around 85% of
respondents thought that the term toxic
masculinity is insulting and probably be
harmful to boys although the direction
of causation isn't definite right do
negative views about masculinity damage
mental health or does low mental health
cause men to view masculinity negatively
it's clear that negative views of
masculinity are linked to well-being to
a significant degree and on the other
hand having a positive view of
masculinity is linked to better mental
well-being and it fits with other
evidence that's overlooked in the media
and everywhere uh that masculinity can
be beneficial to mental health the news
shouldn't really be any surprise to any
average person on the street who
actually recognize the value of
masculinity but much more people who are
in Academia and the media and the
government probably don't there's rare
like exceptions but the majority of
information about masculinity that we
all get exposed to is unreasonably
negative so you can be forgiven for
thinking that men are the oppressors of
women rather than the Protectors of
women and interestingly the study found
that better mental well-being was
associated with believing masculinity
makes men protective of women and worst
mental well-being was associated with
believing masculinity makes men feel
violent toward women so one of the
implications of the study is that if we
want men to have good mental health a
useful strategy might be to help them
appreciate the ways in which their
masculinity can have a positive impact
on their behavior and the people around
them uh so the message to schools uh and
the media and the government from Dr
John Barry is there is more to be gained
by being positive so it's time to stop
being so negative about men and
masculinity and if you were to think
that it's kind of it's almost like an
information Hazard that the
self-fulfilling prophecy of what you
tell
men what you tell people about what they
are and what that
means actually ends up changing the
outcomes of their mental health if you
allow the media and Academia to
perpetuate a negative narrative about
masculinity that is directly linked to
worst mental health outcomes for men
that's almost like I don't know like a a
a
custom pathogen or something that only
impact half of the population and only
impact their mental health but just
allowing that to be perpetuated and the
presumption is oh you know like men are
just whining they need to get over it
it's like hang on a second I thought
that the whole point of this was that we
were trying to bring men along for the
ride and that we were supposed to care
about their mental health so yeah that's
uh like that whole masculinity
conversation I'm really glad that I had
so many great guests on you know George
from the Tin Man just phenomenal super
super interesting dude talking about it
from a leftist perspective uh Christine
Amber talking about it from a feminist
perspective really great and I think
Richard Reeves has got something new
coming out next year too so he'll be
back on I think he might no is going to
be next year uh anyway uh something else
that I realized I came up I came up with
this rule called the parental clout
gauge which is how I work out whether a
news story has reached mainstream
significance or not and it's not when it
Trends on Twitter or hits daytime news
or lands on the front page of a
newspaper it's when my dad messages me
about it on Facebook like that is holy
[__] like this is a big story uh he
messaged me um maybe two years 18 months
ago saying uh I see your friend Mr Rogan
is in the news again and um he messaged
something about Andrew Tate as well it's
like it can be all well and good you
know there can be like millions billions
of tweets trending on Twitter that's
that's fine but when your mom or your
dad messages you about something from
your world that's when you go oh my God
like what what's this has got way out of
hand and way too big so um the rule
stands pretty well to that it's only the
biggest stories that actually cross the
threshold from from Millennial to the
millennial Boomer uh wall that's been
built
um yeah it's funny I put out last week
on my newsletter I put I put out a new
theory about why women support body
positivity so much or at least a
contributing element to it uh so I'm
going to try and dance through this mine
field here I do think that there's some
there there but upfront it's only a
potential Theory so just hear me out
it's also not a comment on anyone as a
person so this is the Rivalry theory of
body positivity female support for body
positivity is at least in part
fueled deep down by female intersexual
competition which pushes women out of
the dating pool by discouraging them
from losing
weight so Bill Burr on one of his
Netflix specials where he did it uh
Outdoors at Red Rocks I think said uh
quote you guys are so into destroying
each other I see all that sneaky [__]
you do ladies if you could just support
the WNBA the way you support a fat chick
who's proud of her body and no longer a
threat to you that that league would be
doing better numbers than the NBA oh my
God you're a goddess you're gorgeous you
look great in that bikini I'd kill
myself if I look like that keep eating
keep eating lose a toe you fat [__]
it's like if you saw an alcoholic oh my
God you're face down passed out your
kids are crying you're a hero you're a
God keep doing what you're
doing so that really got me thinking
like that's ruthless but really really
smart and then the was this new study
that just came out a couple of weeks ago
in the Journal of Personality and
individual
differences that kind of put a little
bit more legitimacy to this idea than
just like some comedians two-minute
segment so they found that women who are
high in intr seexual competitiveness are
more likely to advise women who they
perceive as potential mating threats to
cut off more hair potentially in an
attempt to sabotage their attractiveness
the research res archers studied 450
women who were presented with
hypothetical Salon clients participants
were asked to cut off the amount of hair
to recommend the amount of hair to be
cut off for each client women who
reported higher levels of intersexual
competitiveness were more likely to
recommend that clients have more hair
cut off when the hair was in good
condition and clients expressed a
preference for minimal cutting and the
reason behind this recommendation might
be to subtly manipulate the appearance
of their Rivals right because longer
hair is a cue to Youth and health by
advising more extensive haircuts these
women could potentially diminish the
physical attractiveness of other women
and another Finding is that women advise
clients of similar attractiveness as
themselves to cut off the most hair so
in this scenario participants
effectively targeted women they
perceived as being on the same
attractiveness level as them which
suggests a form of competitive Behavior
called horizontal competition when uh
individuals compete with others of
similar attributes or qualities so the
choice to focus on women of similar
attractiveness may be strategic High
attractive individuals may not pose a
significant mating threat to others
because they likely already have access
to high quality mates on the other hand
targeting less attractive individuals
might not yield the desired results as
their physical appearance might not be
easily harmed through hairstyle changes
right okay so why do I think that this
relates to the body positivity movement
because as far as I can tell the
parallels seem pretty obvious plus you
get social Renown for standing up for a
mistreated group and importantly there's
no body positivity movement for men
right if a guy is unhappy with his body
either publicly or privately most guys
won't say something along the lines of
you know you're absolutely gorgeous as
you are you shouldn't feel any
discomfort between where you are and
where you want to get to uh and women
the justification for this from an
eitech perspective is that women use
indirect aggression way more than men do
so men's intersexual competition is more
like a large Sledgehammer whereas
women's is like a poisoned arrow that
you never see coming
and I'm not saying that this is the
entirety of the justification for female
support for body positivity but I think
it would be naive to say that it doesn't
contribute at all right now I imagine
that this is going to be an unpopular
idea because it's uncomfortable to
realize that what we thought were
altruistic compulsions might have a
selfish undercurrent but inter seexual
competition is a hell of a motive
Ator and it's just an idea but I do
think that there is something here to do
with this and uh if I make it through
the next couple of weeks then I'll be
fine uh another thing that I've been
thinking about a good bit I've started I
guess pivoting back into um a little bit
of productivity stuff
because the show has been uh quite
aggressive plus obviously newtonic
launch which has been like just so much
work behind the scenes and then
live tour which is irland in UK and
Dubai and Canada and America supporting
James Smith later this year and
then just a ton of all of the cinema
episodes everything there's been lots
and lots of kind of pressure behind the
scenes for me uh so I've got back into
thinking about um productivity and there
was this idea from uh Anna cadri that I
totally forgot about and then I was
reminded of it and it's just I've fallen
in love with it so this is productivity
dysmorphia productivity dysmorphia is
the inability to see one's own success
to acknowledge the volume of your own
output it sits at the intersection of
burnout imposter syndrome and anxiety it
is Ambitions Alter Ego the pursuit of
productivity Spurs us to do more while
robbing us of the ability to savor any
success that we might encounter along
the way I've started thinking of this
unhealthy relationship I have with my
professional achievements as
productivity dysmorphia Anna said
I have realized that it is an inability
to see my own success it's like I'm
looking in the mirror of my professional
life and I don't see the published
author staring back at me all I see is a
failure so good dude productivity
dysmorphia is just
this total jaded opinion of what we do
of the achievements that we have made of
the outcomes that we are uh get getting
on a you know minutely or daily basis uh
especially especially if you are a
little bit more isolated when it comes
to the work that you do you know if
you're a work from home kind of person
or work for yourself or you know Nomad
entrepreneur type thing or you know
anybody that just isn't part of a a team
that has very objective metrics of
success because who are you comparing
yourself to right how are you comparing
your PT sessions that you do for your
clients with someone else's well you can
come in and do more PT sessions you're
in earlier or later than everyone else
or you fit more into the same time or
your clients get better outcomes but
it's all kind of like fluffy stuff it's
real hard to work out okay and how much
how much of that is really how much of
that has got there there and how much of
the rest of it is just me sort of bsing
myself and then you know for the people
that work at home dude I went to I went
to an office for the first time in
probably two years the back end of
2021 I went to go and see Mike winnet uh
from the contrepreneur series at his
office
in Warrington which is like not even
Manchester in the northwest of the UK uh
and I went to go and see him and I'd you
know just been locked in the house for
quite a while uh working for the best
part of two years and then snap to kiles
and all the rest of it so it was quite
insulated and forgot
what normal office like was life was
like and you know Mike's team uh
hardworking and they do their stuff and
all the rest of it but I went in and
just observed people you know the all of
the [__] distractions that you have
of an open plan office oh someone's
going to get up and does anybody want a
coffee and then you know for 90 seconds
or two minutes everyone talks about the
different cof yeah I I once had a really
great coffee from this place and are
there any of those biscuits left with
the ones that have got the the raisins
in
what what about the oh we're going to
have to go to the we need to get more
coffee for the whatever and I realized
that my perception of my own work rate
was measured against some totally
arbitrary view of perfection that was
unrealistic anywhere else and it's only
when you get around other people and you
realize especially in somewhere like an
office just how much slippage there is
so much just just things occurring that
just chip away here and there and this
isn't to say that it doesn't happen at
home in fact you know for some people
maybe even for most it also does happen
even more so at home because there's no
one looking over your shoulder to make
sure that you don't scroll Instagram or
or check YouTube or or reply to emails
when you're supposed to be deep workking
or or do something else when you're
supposed to be replying to emails like I
don't think that anyone situation is
necessarily better than the other but
although there are definitely
personalities that lend themselves to
one or the other being better
but there is definitely a case to be
made
that you should see your level of
productivity with a lot more equinity
than you than you do and this kind of
leads into an idea I had about monk mode
so I'd I first learned about monk mode
[__] like
200 18 probably probably 2018 and one of
my friends Jordan sent me this
awesome article from illimitable man who
was kind of red pill before there was
red pill but it was much more uh to do
with productivity and personal men's
advice and exclusively about dating and
doing things for dating um but you know
the last few years we've seen monk mode
really accelerate uh Iman gadzi is a big
proponent of it I think he's got an app
or something that tracks your monk mode
uh so yeah it's grown hugely in
popularity over the last few years and
it's a especially amongst men you know a
popular self-improvement strategy so for
the people that don't know monk mode is
at least uh originally a productivity
strategy where you Retreat from the
world to focus on three eyes there's
introspection isolation and Improvement
and despite the recent ascendants it's
nothing new like I say um that 2014 blog
post that I read from illimitable man uh
described it as uh monk mode is a
temporary form of men going their own
way by cutting yourself off from the
rest of the world for a while you can
fine-tune your focus calibrate your
direction and confront yourself you'll
be acknowledging your weaknesses and
then formulating a plan of action to
deal with them so the focus is on
minimizing your time contributed to
social obligations and junk activities
because these consume much of your time
whilst yielding little to negligible
increases toward your social market
value so monk mode is a serious
commitment not to be half asked you're
either doing it or you're not it'll be a
struggle in the beginning but once You'
fully engaged it becomes beneficial and
productive and dare I say it even an
addictive lifestyle and that's the words
of illimitable man so it's that last bit
even an addictive dare I say even an
addictive lifestyle so for me right the
reason that I can comment on this is
I've gone full monk mode a number of
times in my life with really really
great success I did 2017 did 2018 then I
did M mid 2019 basically straight
through Co until 2021 when I moved out
here I cut out alcohol for over 2,000
days in the last eight years I did 500
days without caffeine 1500 sessions of
meditation over five years of daily
journals filled like over 300 sessions
of Yin Yoga 500 sessions of Stuart
Miguel's big three pretty much all of
that done in a bedroom in Newcastle sat
on my own usually first thing in the
morning and almost all of the most
important progress
that I've ever made was facilitated by a
concentrated period like this so you
might think why have you got a problem
with monk mode if you have benefited
from it so much and it was such a
powerful productivity tool for you but
it's precisely monk Mode's reliable
Effectiveness creates a problem because
the dark side is that addictive
lifestyle thing the issue is monk mode
justifies a retreat from life and risk
and self Adventure as it justifies it as
self-development and it makes you feel
Noble in
isolation so much so that it can become
hard to bring yourself back out and this
means that if you already have a
tendency to live a sheltered slightly
unsocial life you're encouraging
yourself to further abscond away from
ever building a real life support
network which is ultimately the thing
you need the most in the long run and I
saw this in a friend probably a decade
ago so he went on a a fitness journey he
was
already pretty introverted and and shy
then he had a an upcoming fitness
competition which Justified 800 p.m bed
times and militant routines and the
rejection of all social invites the
competition came and
went but the routine didn't change and
it took years for him to reventure out
into some sense of normality and this is
largely a personal reflection for me as
well right the Allure of perpetually
working on yourself is very very high
because Improvement is rewarding but if
you're not careful you can spend the
rest of your life focused on those three
eyes at the expense of the actual reason
that you did monk mode in the first
place to be able to show up in the world
in a better way Bill Perkins the dude
that wrote die with zero who's now
become a really good good friend says
delayed gratification in the extreme
results in no gratification and with
monk mode you practice in private so
that you can perform in public Private
Practice in the extreme results in no
public performance so the fear
is I guess the summary is don't obsess
for too long in solitude for personal
growth or you will struggle to
reintegrate and the best solution that I
found and kind of my strategic tactical
takeaway is to periodize right so you
set a deadline for your monk mode to end
3 to six months I think is a sweet spot
in my experience you can do longer if
you've not done it before and shorter if
you've been doing it a good bit but if
you do not set some sort of end goal
you're just going to continue to blast
through whatever
time what's the reason for you to ever
reintegrate and you hear this in YouTube
comments and I get it like I dude I've
been there I've been the person who has
found the the
comfort of not having to rely on other
people uh of of always saying no to
social invites to the point where you no
longer need to say no especially if
you're a bit of a people pleaser like I
am saying no to things is tough so
creating a routine of people not
inviting you because they know that
you're going to say no also alleviates
the nose that you have to say in future
uh it it is so seductive and enjoyable
to go and do this thing but the reason
that you went to go and do this
isolation personal development thing in
the first place was to then reintegrate
into the world as a leveled up higher
Social market value more equanimous more
calm more peaceful more competent person
with this whole new skill set and this
degree of self-love and and and
self-awareness and if you never actually
bother to
reintegrate or if you even make it so
difficult to reintegrate because you
can't remember what it's like to not do
that it's dangerous like it's it it
there are here there be demons or
whatever it is here here there be
monsters um something that can be really
really good in the first place can end
up being toxic at high doses and I think
monk mode is one of those and I would
have made life a little bit easier if I
just taking small breaks every 6 months
uh or so as opposed to doing these much
bigger Longer stretches where Breaking
the Habit becomes super rough so post
content Clarity is another idea that I
fell in love with and I was you
know largely a lot of what I'm doing is
trying to aggregate interesting [__]
from the internet and books and and
other podcasts and and news and stuff
and then use them to instigate new ideas
on my own or or on the show or in my
writing and um I was finding myself
feeling I don't know
just unsettled sometimes after I would
consume certain bits of content so I
wanted to create a rule for myself that
would help me work out whether the
content that I was consuming was making
my life better or worse uh because the
problem is while you will watch any
anything you're distracted by the
content itself uh which means that you
can't judge how the content impacts you
during the consumption of it the the
creator of whatever you're consuming has
designed a content to be compelling and
to keep you hooked because if they
didn't they'd be beaten by another
Creator who just did that better but
just because something is compelling
doesn't mean that it's good for you you
will happily hate watch adversarial
argumentative videos not because there's
a fascinating question being answered
but because you want to make your team
you want to see your team make the other
team look silly and you pity follow
accounts to check in on the slow motion
car crash of whatever catastrophe is
happening in some person's existence or
you descend into scroll holes and browse
Twitter arguments as your heart rate
gets jacked up through the roof in some
silent apoplectic rage but when you
finish consuming it you forget that you
consumed it and you move on with your
life and you don't assess whether not
that was actually good for you so in
this way you're kind of like a shop
owner in a shop with no walls you're
allowing your most valuable resource
which is your attention to be stolen by
whichever individuals are the most bold
and aggressive and then tomorrow you
forget that they didn't pay you and you
allow them to do it all over again so
the solution I think is to ask yourself
how does watching different creators
make me feel right some YouTube channels
are compelling and lyic hijacking and
they keep me watching but I feel uptight
and and tense and negative and cynical
and zero sum after watching them like I
don't want to message my friends and
tell them that I miss them or pay people
compliments or ring my mom or go outside
and see nature and I feel like the world
is against me and that's not the sort of
content that I want to consume any of no
matter how much it makes my dopamine
fire right on the other hand you can
watch content or read or whatever listen
to stuff that makes you feel the most
connected to the world that makes you
feel hopeful and open and prepared and
informed and light and aligned if you
think that your body is made up of what
you put into your mouth your mind is
made up of things that you put into your
eyes and ears and your content diet
should be Spirulina for the soul not
fast food for your amydala
so thinking very carefully about how you
feel after you consume some
content is the only fix for this because
during the consumption of it it is so
compelling and it's been designed to be
that compelling and if it wasn't
sufficiently compelling you wouldn't be
watching it you'd be watching something
which is more compelling you can't
really defeat the consumption of the
content while you're consuming it what
you can do is assess how you feel
afterward you know if you go back
through your YouTube history which is
something that you can do and think okay
how did I feel after I watched that it's
best to do it probably you know five or
10 minutes after you finish
up check that as well sexy little neonic
cooler
um think about how you feel after you
finished watching something or or
reading something spending time on any
social media and just reflect okay would
I want to do that again tomorrow and if
not start to tune down your use of that
you know there's a not interested or
don't show this Channel or not
interested I think uh to um options that
you can click when you see videos on
your uh home feed so let's say that you
watch some video and you don't like it
uh don't show this channel you will
never see that channel again on your
suggested feed right or in up next there
you go there's that that's fixed uh if
it's more platform-wide you know you can
delete the app uh if you can manage to
stick to it uh George Mac has this
solution of his two phones where he's
got a cocaine phone and he's got a kale
phone uh the cocaine phone is only on
Wi-Fi and the kale phone is the one that
goes around with them all the time the
cocaine phone's got all of the [__]
on it and the kale phone has just got
like uber and and Audible and and Kindle
and stuff like that uh George actually
has an awesome rule uh he calls Max
content razor would you consume your own
content if not don't post
it awesome right you know I asked a
bunch of different guys over the last
year whether or not they would consume
the stuff that they make and there's
definitely a trend amongst the guys
who amongst the guys who
seem more
dissatisfied with their content creation
life that when I ask them that question
there's like
a like dude if it takes you more than
five seconds to say yes that's a [__]
no right um that's one of the advantages
I
think like let's break the fourth wall
about some content creation stuff right
like when
you neonic bottle when you
start doing any content
the accepted wisdom is you should Niche
Down super super hard capture an
audience get the Thousand true fans and
then you can broaden out from there
because it's way easier to penetrate
into a very small cohort or a narrow
cohort than it is to penetrate across
multiple cohorts all at
once the problem is as far as I can see
very few people are just interested in
one thing like there's some obsessive
CrossFit people out there but even the
most obsessive CrossFit person is also
into 70s Jazz you know and and romcoms
and uh loves to play pickle ball like
you know this the cooking Bakery
whatever everyone is this Frankenstein's
monster of
idiosyncratic limbs that's kind of being
attached to a torso and by niching Down
super super hard what it does is get you
known very very well for one thing but
in future that can often become your
uh kind of like an Achilles heel but
it's it's almost a restrictive label you
know Zach my
housemate started off in Fitness for a
long time and crushed he's got some of
the best fitness videos if you're
talking Olympic weightlifting I think
he's the best on all of YouTube and
Olympic weightlifting is a super popular
sport but he's now at a stage of his
life where he may never go back and
compete in Olympic weightlifting again
and he does much he's got way more
varied interests he's interested in
philosophy and psychology and human
nature and culture okay so he now has to
Pivot from that super like tight defined
uh Niche to try and broaden out and as
he does that the people who came for one
thing are going to leave to look it's
not impossible to do and I think that
Zach will do a good job of it so if you
want to watch if you want to watch how
someone does it I guess just watch his
channel over the next couple of years
but certainly from my side the um would
you consume your own content if not
don't post
it if you are not engaged with the stuff
that you are
producing online the sort of things that
you're talking about the kind of stories
that you're sharing on your Instagram
Etc just stop like don't do it just make
stuff and share
stuff that you like not that you think
people will like because ultimately if
you're only doing what people what you
think people will like you become a
puppet and you Outsource your sense of
selfworth and all of the content
creation to the crowd you know these
episodes I don't know it's what an hour
and 10 minutes or something me waffling
on about bro philosophy horeshit that
I've like pulled out of my pulled out of
the last nine months of life in the
hopes that something's interesting but
it's what I would have wanted 10 years
ago like this entire show is what I
wished that I had when I was 25 and
starting to realize there's probably
more to the world than just getting
drunk and partying all right where do I
start so and it still largely is all of
the lessons still largely are so yeah
all right Let's do let's do two more
I've got this this like double up from
Mark Manson which is great so this is um
about
resilience the willingness to be
disliked is a superpower if you develop
the willingness to be disliked you will
inevitably have the courage to do the
hard things that most people are not
willing to
do this will then imbue your life with a
sense of meaning and importance it will
also lead to success that others will be
too intimidated to go after but I would
go even further than this I would argue
that until you're comfortable with the
disapproval of others you are not truly
a free individual yourself you must
develop the ability to be disliked in
order to free yourself from the prison
of other people's opinions learn to do
what's right even if others think it
might be wrong
learn to tolerate criticism and negative
feedback because that's what will make
you better learn to be laughed at hated
on and trolled because if you can become
comfortable with the hate you'll be
[__] Unstoppable and he's got this
other uh what's that BG the courage to
be disliked by some Japanese author
whose name I'm going to absolutely
Butcher and I haven't read but I've
heard is really great um he also taught
me about choose your suck every single
Pursuit no matter how wonderful and
exciting and glamorous it may initially
seem comes with its own brand of [__]
sandwich its own lousy side effects
everything sucks some of the time you
just have to decide what sort of suckage
you're willing to deal with so the
question is not so much what are you
passionate about the question is what
are you passionate enough about that you
can endure the most disagreeable aspect
of the work because if you love
something and want something enough
whatever it is then you don't really
mind eating the [__] sandwich that comes
with it and Mark said this on the
episode that we did a couple of months
ago where he
mentioned that when the Blogger sphere
started kicking off a few years ago
maybe a decade ago or so uh he would go
to these conventions and I think his
blog posts he would maybe do
multiple thousand 2,000 3,000 word
essays per week and he would be asked I
think by other
people how he was able to put out such a
high volume of content and he said
something along the lines of like it it
it just comes it comes a combination of
easily to me and the difficulty comes
easily to me
too I like a that's interesting the
difficulty comes easily to me too like
that's the [__] sandwich that he's
prepared to eat and I think it helps to
make you much more aligned with what you
want anything that you want to pursue is
going to be it's going to have an amount
of associated pain and the best
predictor is not who loves the thing the
most the best predictor is who else can
deal with the suck that comes along with
whatever you want to do the best so yeah
orienting yourself toward the
difficulties as opposed to toward the
pleasures will no one or very few people
stop doing a thing or don't achieve
success because of a lack of pleasure
it's more an increase of pain I think
yeah sure you need positive
reinforcement but you get that from the
dopamine of just making progress in any
case the
pains that you come up against the
burnout the self-doubt the oh god I've
got to do that thing I got to get the
paintbrush out and get the easel out or
whatever uh that's really what's going
to cause you to stop as far as I can see
so yeah Orient yourself toward the pains
uh and that would be the best way to do
this uh anyway new tonic.com go and try
this get yourself a case right now it's
available on Amazon Prime next day
delivery UK and us you going get that
right now at nut tonic.com or search on
Amazon for Neu t o N I see and that's
pretty much it I will see you in 98 more
episodes